[Music]
hi everybody
thank you for coming to my talk today my
name is scott churchill i'm the vice
president of scientific development at
mcr labs
we do compliance testing for cannabis
and cannabis products
we're going to be taking a look at an
evaluation we did on the impact of a
growing environment on the production of
secondary metabolites by cannabis plants
in addition to
being the vice president here i'm also
one of the founders and this was my
first company where
i was part of a startup
and a number of the
experiences i had i considered to be
stressors and those stressors as i was
going through that forced me to adapt by
developing new techniques uh greater
knowledge base
resources for dealing with a variety of
things
and that kind of
is what we're looking at today with
plants if we have um you know different
stressors do we get different responses
from the plants
so
um
when you when you think about cannabis
cultivation options you have
indoor and outdoor you you have
greenhouses and and all of those
different environments have different um
things associated with them in out in
indoor grow allows you to control
a lot more tightly all of the variables
um that the plant will
be facing
it also allows you to have a perpetual
harvest and you're likely to be able to
better control microbiological
contamination indoors and prevent any
kind of
accidental exposure to pesticides from a
nearby
farmer
putting down
pesticides on their crops
but it is more expensive and you it is a
heavier impact on the environment in
terms of
the lighting and the heating and the
cooling and the control of the
environment overall so
on the outdoor grows you get you know
free sunshine you get free rain and you
have um
less expense associated with
trying to scale agro
and
there's a lot of a lot of good reasons
but you need the right environment and
you don't have as tight a control over
some of the variables that we mentioned
a greenhouse is a is a good compromise
and it to the extent and to the way you
leverage it you can get some of the
benefits from both indoors or outdoor
growing
but
what is the impact on plant compound
production
between these different that's the
question you know we're going to be
taking a closer look at
but when we look at that we have to take
into account that there are a lot of
different
variables that affect
what a plant's going to produce
the first and most obvious one is the
plant genetics you have some plants that
have been
selectively bred for a period of time to
produce
either high thc numbers or high cbd
numbers or some kind of ratio of the two
people are looking at cultivars
specifically for cbg or other types of
cannabinoids they're selectively
breeding them to
turn off or on things and when you do
that you
as you continuously do that over time
you start to trim the branches of
possibilities of those plants and what
they can produce
other factors that
could affect the plants
production of secondary metabolites is
nutrition and irrigation
lighting whether it's
indoors with a limited spectrum and
tight control over time and intensity or
outdoors where the intensity changes and
the time changes depending on the season
and where you are
and the orientation
indoors you have a lot more control
about centering the light on the plants
whereas
outdoors you have to pick where you're
going to put your plants and let them
take advantage of the sun that way
so our our hypothesis was that we could
control for the genetics by
taking clones with the same genetic
information
and
use that control to see if they express
different secondary metabolites as a
function of their growing condition
we did this by
enlisting three cultivators who
had a total of five different cultivars
and for each cultivar we took a clone
and we split it between indoor and
outdoor growing environments
we
had the cultivators then take it through
vegetation flowering drying and curing
to a finished flower product
and then they brought the samples to two
laboratories
for analysis
in the two laboratories one of them was
mine we employed a targeted
quantitative analysis where
we do the compliance testing so we test
for all of the
usual compounds 17 cannabinoids 23
terpenes 4 heavy metals
and we do that using
lcuv gcf id and icpms
our partner lab
that collaborated with us on this was
psyx and they used a qtos they did an
untargeted search where anything that
ionized
they collected spectra on
and then would do an analysis of well
they did two things one is they did
principal component analysis to see if
there were
categories of compounds that were unique
to indoor versus outdoor as well as um
being able to take the some of the
spectra
that were obtained for the different
growing conditions
and compare it to a library to to get a
pretty good idea of of what we were
looking at
so um we're going to
take a look at the results we're going
to summarize the overall findings then
we're going to look a little bit at the
quantitative results followed by the
qualitative results the untargeted
search
the results show
what we were expecting to find which is
that
the
the trends show higher secondary
metabolite production in outdoor grown
plants
the
untargeted shows uh not only that the
compounds uh secondary metabolites were
elevated in the
in the outdoor grows but the type of
compound produced in the outdoor grows
was
different had a different chemical
profile
than the indoor growth
we also observed that there were strain
specific trends this is where
the genetics of the plant had a greater
impact on what they produced
versus the
environmental conditions whether it was
indoor or outdoor
did not have as as high an impact
we also
took two of the
cultivars a total of four plants indoor
and outdoor and we did heavy metals
analysis on it and we had a
interesting finding there where
in both cases the indoor samples showed
detection of cadmium where the outdoor
samples did not
it's a very limited data set and we're
going to have to take a closer look at
that
down the road
this
table shows that in 5 out of 5 samples
the terpenes and the cbga
in the targeted search were elevated in
outdoor
outdoor grown samples over indoor grown
samples
in 4 out of 5 cases delta 9 thc which is
a degradation product of thca
was elevated in the indoor samples and
in
three out of five cases thca was was
higher in the in the outdoor samples
we also
like i said before saw that there was
cadmium detected in the two indoor
samples as compared to outdoor samples
that we looked at
this is the um
principal component plot for the indoor
outdoor differences and this is just
showing you that the
principal component 2 is
consistently elevated in the indoor
samples and
depressed in the outdoor samples
this is a breakdown of the different
analytical targets that created those
principal components and we're going to
be taking a look a little bit later
at some of the outdoor the
targets that were identified to be
associated with outdoor
ground samples
and
this is where we got
those targets from
this shows the unique strains where
you know field trip number nine and
starfighter
both their chemical profiles whether
they were grown indoors or outdoors did
not dramatically change
um how how their
their secondary metabolite production
was geared towards so
they they are examples uh likely of uh
selective breeding kind of minimizing
um how much variation you can expect by
varying the the environment that you're
you're growing your plants and the
inputs
and this is an example of one of the
outdoor
target outdoor associated targets that
we identified
it's got a mass to charge ratio of 271
and
on the left hand side you can see it's
always elevated in outdoor and never
elevated on the indoor and on the
right-hand side that's just a plot that
allows you to see the difference between
the outdoor a little bit easier
so we did a library match to this and it
it
matched up very well to apogenin
this is a compound that's of therapeutic
interest because of its
antioxidant anti-inflammatory
and blood pressure reducing
characteristics it's also antibacterial
and antiviral so it's being looked at
for a number of
different applications it might be
important
to
to have plants that express this if
that's
something that you're trying to
accomplish
and it's heavily
it's heavily biased towards producing
more of it in the outdoor samples versus
the indoor samples
now
on on this one we see the same trend
it's
an unknown with a mass charge ratio of
433
and it's
always elevated in outdoor it's it's
hardly detected in the indoor samples
and
we did the library match and it turns
out that it's by texan
vitexin has also got the therapeutic
potential it's
thought to it's they're hopefully
looking at it for potentially
modulating hormones reducing the
severity and the symptoms of ems
and they're also looking at
treating migraines and joint conditions
with it
the trend continues with this
outdoor always elevated indoor not
really present and it turns out that
it's a sugar conjugated version of
vitaxin
by texan ramnicide and it's also being
evaluated as a potential therapeutic
i didn't see anything specific for that
alone i saw it mentioned in studies that
were looking at flavonoids in general
which is a
hot topic in
plant therapeutics
and then we also saw
an unknown at 449 master charge ratio
again elevated and outdoors not present
so much in the indoor
and it was a library match for orienten
that's
being looked at for anti-aging and
anti-cancer treatments and i didn't
mention it on the previous slides but if
you look at these compounds they are
very oxygenated as compared to the
typical terpene profiles
the outdoor grown samples tend to have
more oxygenation they tend to have
more sugar conjugation they tend to be
larger more complicated molecules as a
as a differentiation between the indoors
and the outdoors so
um and then
you know in
in some instances that i highlighted
here there are compounds of therapeutic
interest
so
going back to the the variables that we
talked about um you know indoor versus
outdoor
uh and and the fact that we we did see
um you know two strains that had heavy
metals detected in the indoor
we don't have enough information to know
whether or not uh feeding or water
source was was the cause of that so
that's something that we're going to
try and look at a little bit more
carefully in a separate study
but we did we were able to
see an increase in the amount and type
of secondary metabolites produced in
outdoor samples versus indoor samples
overall
and in the outdoor samples we were able
to identify
principal components to separate indoor
versus outdoor
the indoor samples were biased towards
producing the more common
routinely measured
lighter
simpler
terpene
secondary metabolites whereas the
outdoors
had the
the larger or more
complex molecules being produced
in the outdoor samples so
we also saw that some strains do not
respond to the different environments
that they're in they they basically
produce what they produce and
you can do it indoors and outdoors and
get very similar results so
very very interesting findings um
i think that
it you know in conclusion
um
the cultivation method does impact both
the uh the type and amount of secondary
metabolites that are produced
this this phenomena can be
somewhat diminished by
specific strains
my current theory is that it has to do
with how much selective breeding has
gone on and how much the
the options of
the plants have been trimmed out by
those breeding programs
and
of interest for further studies is
trying to identify
which environmental conditions from the
outdoors are
reproducible indoors that way you would
be able to
put in the appropriate
conditions to get indoor grows to
produce um the
the
secondary metabolites that might be of
therapeutic interest that that could be
important in in places where you don't
have outdoor growing as an option
and it will be important if you want to
have perpetual harvest
if you want to have tighter control over
microbial contamination
but nevertheless the
the fact that the
production of metabolites is impacted
this means that when you're
when you're making decisions about your
grow you have to factor in in addition
to all of the factors that we talked in
in the beginning
in terms of the cost and the the control
that you get and the freedom and so
forth you also have to ask whether or
not you're attempting to produce these
molecules of interest
and until we can find a way to tease out
the the outdoor conditions that result
in those molecules outdoor is is the
only way that that i'm aware of that you
can
kind of put the plant in a position to
make those molecules um or favor those
molecules at least
um so for future studies that's what
we're going to be looking at as well as
taking out
a separate study to look at heavy metals
and whether or not there are
conditions
that are in the outdoors versus the
indoors that are impacting whether or
not they take up heavy metals
and um seeing if we can identify those
as a possible way to prevent you know
those those types of accumulations
and with that i want to
thank everybody for your time and i want
to let you know that if there are
any questions you can reach out to me
i'm at scott c mcrlabs.com
and i'd like to hear anything that you
guys have to say about this or any
questions that you might have
always looking forward
looking for opportunities to collaborate
with the community and answer questions
that otherwise can't be answered without
access to analytics so
in addition to the compliance testing we
do we try to add in
experiments and initiatives and
collaborations that allow us to
answer questions that are important to
the community
with that thank you and have a great day
you